the recording on. So I want to pick up in volume 15 from February the 3rd, 1923.
Jesus and Louisa are the two dying ones. I felt life missing in me, Louisa said, because
of the privation of my sweet Jesus. And if he moves in my interior, he makes himself
seen inside the horrifying sea of sins of people. Now it's like we know the divine
will is a sea. And here she's saying the sea of sins. Okay, so I want to give you two
Thessalonians 2 7 there. Now the horrifying sea of sins is the rebellion against God's will.
And you're going to discover that it is the secret and deceptive plans for all kinds of war.
It's 1923. So he calls it a sea of sins. We know what the sins are because it's
pride and arrogance rebelling against God, creating death and disaster for us.
Then unable to endure any more, Louisa said, I was lamenting strongly. And he as though
stirred by my moans came out of that sea and clasping me told me, my daughter, what's wrong?
I heard your elements. I heard the rattle of your agony. And I put everything aside. That's
his running of the universal in case Louisa doesn't know what he's putting aside. I put
everything aside to come and help you and sustain you. My daughter have patience. We are the two
poor dying ones, you and I for the good of humanity. So this is the death resurrection,
death resurrection that the two of them are going through all the time. Louisa has to go through it
in imitation of him because she's the victim soul. So we're doing it for the good of humanity.
But while we are dying, love sustains us so as not to let us die. Now that's divine love that's
agape, divine love. It's not human love. To give help to our poor humanity, which lies
as though dying in the sea of its many sins. Okay. So humanity is dying in the sea of its sins.
Into that sea goes Jesus, the great victim. And he brings Louisa, the great victim. And divine love
sustains the two of them as they make reparation to try and lift up poor humanity from its death
to life. Have you got the picture? Okay. So as he was saying this, it seemed that the waves of that
sea would submerge the two of us. Who can say what we were suffering? And since in those waves,
we could see preparations for war. There's a lot of plurals given in the text, which are
okay for Italian, but not English. And I said to him my life, who knows how long this second turmoil
that's World War II will last? If the first one lasted so long, that's 14 to 18, four years,
what's going to happen with the sect, which seems longer, which was six years, remember 39 to 45?
Okay. So she knew in 1923 that World War II would be longer than World War I. Okay. So there's
your Amos 3-7 again. The Lord tells his saints ahead of time and Isaiah 64-10. So look at the
distance with which he can see this clearly. And Jesus all afflicted said, yes, indeed, it will be
larger, but it will not last for too long. Ask anybody between 39 to 45 for their opinion.
Because I will put my hand into it, and the scourges of heaven will muffle those of earth.
This is the very bad weather in which many soldiers died. Remember, many soldiers died in the snow
in Russia? Okay. Just to give one example that we know of, that I know of, because I just haven't
looked into this deeply enough. Therefore, let us pray. And you, he said, I want you never to go out
of my will. So February the 13th, 1923, you put a big ring around, be faithful and attentive. This
is essential for us. Okay. I felt all afflicted, Louisa said, and my sweet Jesus making himself seen
for just a little told me, my daughter courage, be faithful and attentive to me because faithfulness
and attentiveness produce equality of humors. Now try a dictionary today for humors. They don't
have it. We would say perfect balance. Okay. Now, I'm only guessing if you have any more
insight, it'd be wonderful. To me, the humors is emotional balance. It's the way we would put it.
You've got some emotional intelligence. Yes, it's an emotional thing, I think.
Well, he's talking about balance. Yeah. Yeah. I think emotional intelligence is a different
aspect. Yeah. But these kinds of things, when they're using old-fashioned words,
we really have to search to try and get what they're at. So it produces this perfect balance.
And the other way I put it is that the state of mind, and as John said, your moods are balanced.
Is that okay? So we'll put both in there just to try and cover it. And it forms one single
humor. So that means there's calm in the soul establishing perfect peace. Now, the perfect peace,
Jesus said, he wanted us to have perfect peace in John 14, 27. And the perfect peace is Philippians
4, 7. The peace that passes all understanding and guards your heart and your mind in Christ
Jesus. Now, he's been telling that this is volume 15. And he's been telling us since volume one,
that he can only truly operate in us when we are at peace. Hence, from volume one, he was telling us
to get rid of all inner disturbance. Do you remember? Okay. Because Satan works best in disturbance,
and God works best in peace. And Jesus is the king of peace. So here we're back to this
peace and balance. And you notice this with people who are steady in their relationship with God,
that there is a peace in them that's undisturbed, no matter what's happening on the outside.
And there's a balance in their lives. They don't go to extremes, either to the right or to the left.
But the way the church has put that from time immemorial is this. Virtus in Medio stat.
Virtue walks the middle road. That's the road of balance. Okay. Do you want it in Latin?
V-I-R-T-U-S. Virtus in I-N. Medio, M-E-D-I-O. Stat, S-T-A-T. That literally means virtue
stands in the middle. Okay. So no extremes. You can find people who see Virtus in Medio stat.
M-E-D-I-O is Medio. Virtus in Medio stat. You will find some people who appear to be very religious,
and yet they can go off the top with anger and all kinds of stuff and say, "Hey, where does the
religion fit into that?" And you see what the Lord is talking about us here is bringing us into
divine order. Now in divine order, everything is balanced. So the anger is balanced with tranquility
and patience is balanced with something else. Everything is balanced. So you don't go off the
top and you don't blow the lid. Do you know what I mean? That's a very early stage where things are
not in control and not balanced. So what he wants to do is to establish perfect peace in us. Okay.
Now I have this written down somewhere in my office. You keep them in perfect peace whose mind
is stayed on you. It's St. Paul somewhere. I look at it afterwards and give it to you. You keep them
in perfect peace whose mind is stayed on you. And this is what he's talking about here.
You keep them in perfect peace whose mind is stayed on you. So that's the be faithful and
attentive. The mind stayed on you. And that's Paul. So this has been known from the beginning.
So he wants to establish this perfect peace. Therefore this perfect balance in the soul. Now
if there's perfect balance in the soul, that person is going to be calm and they will be calm
under trial as well. And this piece renders her dominator. I think a better word is victor.
In such a way that she does whatever she wants and reaches wherever she wants. In other words,
there's nothing out of balance. Now to reach wherever you want means that you still have
this competence of mind to be able to put everything into the divine will and to let everything be
on a divine level. Is that okay? To do whatever you want means that your will is free. It's not
actually dominated by passions or sins or anything else. Your will is actually free.
Especially for one who lives in my will that's living in the divine will. It is the same as
happens to the song. It never changes. Now my book says one is its act. That's not English.
Okay. The the sun has one single act which is to give light. Okay. And so its act is to unleash
light and heat from its sphere. It does not do something today and something else tomorrow.
You see that's a very early stage where a person has enthusiasm today and then they're not interested
tomorrow. The perfect balance means that you will go steadily on what God wants you to do.
So the divine will keeps you on the track all the time. And so it's always faithful and constant.
Now look at the word constant and doing the same thing. So this is talking about a life that is
properly disciplined. It's properly disciplined. Now notice I use the word properly because some
people go into discipline to such a degree that that's out of balance. You know what I mean?
Doing the same thing. So the faithfulness of the sun to give light every single day,
every single day, every single year, every single century that he's talking about that we should
be constant. And while the the sun has only one act as this act ascends and hits the surface of
the earth how you have to add the word it causes many different acts to happen. Okay. I'm trying
to change that into English what we're reading. The acts in other words is he's going to tell you
what the many acts are. So the sun's acts are almost innumerable. If it finds a flower half
closed with the kiss of its light and with its heat it opens it gives it color and fragrance.
If it finds a non-ripe fruit it matures and gives it sweetness. If it finds fields that are green
it makes them golden. If it finds air that is putrid it purifies with the kiss of light. In sun
to all things it gives what they need for their existence on the earth. Now this is precisely
what the divine will is after. That if we get into the divine will and become stable and constant
and balanced and living in this peace but doing everything thought word action
body movement step is that the way Louisa puts it doing everything in the divine will
then everything that God wants for us we can have innumerable effects upon innumerable souls.
That's what he's trying to get across to us. Okay. So you're doing your one act but it's having a
innumerable effects just as the sun only sends its light and it has innumerable effects. Okay.
In sun to all things the sun gives what they need and their existence on this earth to be able to
produce the usefulness which they contain and which has been established by God. So that means
that our acts will enable souls to be able to do what God wants them to do as well. So by its
faithfulness and by doing always the same thing the sun is the fulfillment of the divine will for
all created things. So you can see where he's going with telling us he wants us faithful and
attentive. If the sun were not always equal that is constant in sending its light the word equal
there is not correct. If it's not constant because it's talking about constancy how many
fluctuations how many disorders there would be on the earth and man would not be able to make
any calculation either about fields or plants. I mean if you didn't know whether it was winter or
summer how can you decide on a harvest you just can't do it. He would say if the sun doesn't send
me its light and its heat I don't know if I'm supposed to harvest or whether the fruits will
mature or not. Now the important thing is the same thing happens with the soul who is faithful
and attentive. In my will she has one act never mind about English okay but its effects are
innumerable. Now he's saying about the acts of the soul exactly what he said about the sun.
On the other hand if she's in constant and inattentive neither she nor I can make any calculation
but establishing any good. In other words I can't run the kingdom because I can't depend on this
little sun giving its light. Okay that's a very important teaching and needs a good bit of
explanation so chew on it. Okay so February the 16th 1923 I have a VIP on this one we're going to
be talking about a living crucifix. I was doing my usual adoration to the crucified one Louisa said
and abandoning all of myself to his lovable will but as I was doing this I felt my beloved Jesus
move in my interior and he said my daughter hurry hurry quickly hasten do your course in my divine
will keep going through all that my humanity did in the supreme will so that you may unite your
acts with mine and those of my mother. Now notice the quick get on with it we're inclined to sit back
and say well there are other people doing acts besides me and so we may not be as energetic
about doing the acts as we should be and it has been decreed Louisa that if one creature does not
enter into the eternal volition to render all our acts triple that's Jesus blessed mother and
Louisa. This supreme volition will not descend upon the earth to carry out its life in the human
generations. Okay and it wants the courtage of the triple acts in order to make itself known
therefore hasten. Now an aspect of this that I don't usually cover because it will get me into
trouble in the sense that it'll get me into too much scripture and will go much slower at this
thing but I'm just going to give you a hint. Jesus says if you don't do your acts to make our acts
triple that's Jesus Mary and herself my plans for the human race won't happen. Okay so write down
Joel chapter 3 1 to 5. It means that Joel chapter 3 1 to 5 won't happen that is the universal Pentecost.
So he's telling Louisa that your acts are so important that scriptural texts are depending on it.
Now I didn't want to go down this road before because it'll bring us too much into
into so it's something you do on a day rather than. Oh yeah of course yes because you see
the the reign of the divine will is in fact Joel chapter 3 1 to 5 that the spirit of God is to
fall upon all flesh because the reign of God throughout the ... okay the reign of God throughout
the earth can only happen if the spirit of God comes on all flesh. The spirit of God can't come
on all flesh unless all of them are prepared. So all that we're doing in the divine will is
preparing the human race to open up to God is that okay but I did this is my first time to give you
that aspect of this these writings okay so I just wanted to put the the definitive Pentecost
wouldn't happen okay so poor Louisa so my heading for the next paragraph is the cross is made up of
humanity you get this in the hours of the passion as well. It's human beings that make up the cross
and I'm there as well. Jesus kept silent and Louisa said I felt myself as though
flung into the holy eternal volition but I'm not able to say what I was doing. I can only say that
I found all the acts of Jesus and I placed my own which is what he wants us to do. Each one of us
must put our drop of water into his wine. Then he continued to speak my daughter how many things
will my will make known of what my humanity worked in this divine will. He's going to do that as we
go along. In order to carry out the perfect and complete redemption my humanity had to do that
in the sphere of eternity it had to be done on the divine will level otherwise it wasn't
going to reach everybody. Here is the necessity of an eternal will. If my human will did not have
an eternal will with itself all my acts would be limited and finite. Now he's trying to tell us
what our acts are when we're not in the divine will so they're small and they're finite but with
the divine will the it is divine will they are endless and they're infinite therefore my pains
my cross had to be endless and infinite that is to fit all humanity past present and future into it
and the divine will made my humanity find all these pains and crosses so much so that my humanity
sorry that the divine will you have to clarify the it every time because it can represent different
things and that the divine will laid me over the whole human family now in the in the margin all I
have is me too and it laid me Jesus said over the whole human family from the first to the last
and I absorbed all kinds of pains within myself and each soul formed my cross this is terribly
important this is terribly important we're in there it's part of us so when we do the acts that he's
asking us to do we're merely cooperating with the redemption of the rest of the people in the cross
okay so my cross was as long as the centuries are and will be and as wide
as the human generations in other words every single human being from Adam to Zachary is in the cross
that's why he fell three times under the cross not because of the weight of the wood it was because
the weight of humanity that he was carrying yeah and it was not just the little cross of cavalry
that's the wood on which the Jews crucified me that one was nothing but a simile of the long
cross on which the supreme will kept me crucified okay there's a lovely expression and I just
remembered it now and again I don't have the reference he loved me and he died for me that's
Paul he loved me and he died for me you see he wants us to hear that not only is your name
on the cross but you're in it and you're in the whole mystery whether you like it or not you're
actually there and therefore the pains of your life are different to what you think they're all
part of that mystery they're not just isolated you struggling with something do you know what I mean
they're all part of that mystery and you overcoming whatever it is that you have to overcome in your
life because the church says that everybody has a predominant fault so that means a particular
area in which you're struggling okay and your victory over that particular area is essential
for redemption absolutely essential it's you letting him conquer and when you conquer then
millions of other people get the grace to either start the battle continue the battle or complete
the battle so what you do is essential for them one of the pictures of Elizabeth Wang on radiant
light dot org is of a person going towards heaven and they can only take steps very slowly
but only if you ever noticed in your own spiritual life that the steps you take are slow
and the person wanted to know why can't I go quicker and the Lord said look behind you and on the
folk thousands of people so the step forward was difficult because you're carrying them with you
these are people you don't know you'll only know them in heaven and it's people who are connected
to you in some way either through struggles through things that happened to you through a way of life
through a ministry that's given to you or something there's some kind of a connection
and therefore and there's grace running through these channels these are all channels if I can
put them to make sense but it means that every single step forward we take is essential for
everybody else and that kind of thing you need as encouragement okay so the little cross of
Calvary on which the Jews crucified me says that wasn't it that one was nothing but a
simile of the long cross on which the supreme will kept me crucified now Jesus tells us in the
Christmas novina that it was crucified from day one okay so each person I hate the word creature
each person formed the length and the width of the cross and as they formed it they remained
grafted to that same cross we're part of the mystery because the cross is him redeeming us
and the divine will laying me over it and crucifying me made the cross not only my own
but of all those who formed the cross this is why I needed the sphere of eternity to keep this cross
this terrestrial space would not be enough to contain it isn't that something okay
so I've written beside that Ephesians 1 10 and 11 Ephesians chapter 1 verses 10 and 11
Colossians 1 and chapter sorry chapter 1 and verse 18 so again the next paragraph is the cross
is made up of souls okay oh how much will how much will creatures love me when they come to know
what my humanity did in the divine will now beside that I want you to put Hosea 4 6
lack of knowledge the people perish okay and this is why we've got to make this known to everybody
how much they will come to know me when they realize what my humanity did in the divine will
and what it made me suffer for love of them that's that thing in St Paul he died for me the realization
of it my cross this is as clear as daylight was not of wood no it was made up of souls it was them
that I felt palpitating in the cross on which the divine will laid me and the divine will let
none of them escape me in other words whether they end up in hell or not he still paid for all
of their sins okay and the divine will give a place to each one and in order to give a place to
all it stretched me in such a harrowing way and with pains so atrocious that I could call the pains
of my passion little and reliefs so I want to give you Isaiah 53 verses 4 to 5
therefore hasten he said to Louisa so that my will may make known all that this eternal volition
operated in my humanity this knowledge will win so much love that human beings will bend
now that's the incredible bit to bend means to bend our stubborn hearts and to bend our
prideful wills that's what the bending is and will allow the divine will to reign in them now
notice it all hinges on knowledge they must know about this so I want to give you Sam 22 verses
25 to 31 Sam 22 verses 25 to 31 now that's at the very end of the Sam describing the passion
okay it's a wonderful prophecy about the future at the end of that Sam and it actually ends with
a consummata mess it's finished and in it he says the whole earth will one day come back to the
Lord I often go back to that when the news is too bad I often go back to Sam 22 and he says this
is what he said what happened and we're holding out for it it's going to happen that humanity will
one day no matter what the conditions are they will one day come back to him okay so that's a
wonderful passage it's a great thing so as Jesus was saying this he showed so much tenderness
and so much love that amazed Louisa said to him my love why do you show so much love when you speak
about your will such that it seems that if you wanted to release another you from within yourself
because of the great love that you feel while if you speak about something else this excessive
love doesn't show in you and he said my daughter do you want to know when I speak about my will
to make it known to humanity I want to infuse in her my own divinity now this is this is him telling
you what his agenda is when he reveals the divine will to us it's because he wants to put his divine
will into each one of us to reign okay I do it because I want to infuse in her that's the soul
my own divinity and therefore another me so my whole love enters the field in order to do this
well his love is triune father son and spirit okay my whole love enters the field in order to do
this and I love her as I love myself now I need to give you john 15 9 there as the father has loved
me so I love you I also want to give you Jeremiah 31 3 I have loved you with an everlasting love
so this is why you see that while I speak about my will my love seems to overflow out of its boundaries
in order to form the dwelling of my will in the heart of the creature now there's God's agenda
he wants to form his dwelling place now from from the book of genesis to the book of revelation
the whole thing can be summarized with God wanting to find a dwelling place on earth
and he would set up the tabernacle in the wilderness they would eventually defile it he'd try something
else and he'd try a temple he'd get holy people and all the whole thing is a struggle to try and
find a dwelling place on earth and Jesus put it into his own prayer very succinctly that your will
would be done on earth as it is in heaven therefore that the earth itself would be the altar of God
okay so that's what he wants is to have his dwelling place on earth why does he want his dwelling
place on earth the answer to that is in revelation 12 because in revelation 12 you're told about
the war in heaven and the rebellion of the angels and the amazing thing is that when the good angels
through the bad angels out they didn't go to hell that's the most startling thing that people don't
notice they didn't go to hell they came to planet earth and they decided that they would choose
planet earth as the place where they would reign in rebellion against God but planet earth had been
chosen as the altar of God and so in defiance to God's will Satan said no you're not having the earth
and you're not having the creatures on the earth so that's that's the battle that's going on all
the time okay and that's why the Lord wants to get his altar back on the earth and that the whole
earth itself should be the altar of God and he'll get it someday but it doesn't look like he's
getting it tomorrow on the other hand he said when I speak about something else it's my virtues
that I infuse not the whole of myself just something outside of that and according to the virtues that
I keep manifesting to the soul I love her as creator or as father or as redeemer or teacher or doctor
whatever and therefore there's not the exuberance of love as when I want to form another me in other
words when I want to release myself upon the earth as distinct some some of my effects okay
so he wants to have another me in each one of us all right
so February the 22nd 1923 Louisa is back to worrying about whether she's having real
experience or not she says I was very distressed by the thought that my state might be a continuous
pretense what a bolt from the blue this is for me so she's not expecting this temptation to come to
her so she says it's a bolt from the blue it calls all storms upon me and puts me below all the
wicked and even the very damned she says because it puts her into total crisis and she's supposed
to be calm she's supposed to be balanced she's supposed to be attentive and all the rest of it
here she is in an absolute hurricane but what what grieves me the most is being unable to get
out of this state of pretense is what she says now if you know your gospel the one thing that Jesus
condemned was pretense he called it hypocrisy and if you want to just look it up just put CF
meaning to look at something up it's Matthew 15 and it's verses 1 to 10 and the whole of
Matthew 23 now in Matthew 15 verses 1 to 10 one of the things he does is he quotes Isaiah and he
says these people honor me with lip service but their hearts are far from me I'm afraid we're back
to that and so a soul more perverted than I am has never existed upon the earth she said but what
grieves me the most is being unable to get out of this pretense for I would confess my sin and at
the cost of my life I would not do it again Jesus who is so good in his infinite mercy would forgive
my soul the most wicked of all and so the heading I want to give you for the next paragraph is Jesus
a response to her and he says the higher the sanctity has to go the lower the humility has to go
that's why she keeps on being plunged into these crises so the higher the sanctity the lower the
humility that is perfectly logical to us the higher the high rise building has to go the deeper
the foundations have to go as well then after I had gone through one of these storms my beloved
Jesus made himself seen and I said to him my beloved Jesus what an ugly thought this is
well please do not let pretense pretense you see is the work of Satan hypocrisy do not let pretense
have existence over me rather send me death but do not let me offend you okay don't let me offend
you with the ugliest vice which is pretense it terrorizes me it crushes me it annihilates me it
snatches me away from your sweet arms and puts me under the feet of all that of the damned so I want
to also give you another reference which is to Timothy three five and that's where St. Paul said
there'll be a terrible crisis in the church eventually I think we're in it where people would
have the outer form of religion without having the inner reality of it which is pretense okay
in other words they go to church they don't believe a thing or they get children baptized
because they want to get them into school or they confirm them and then they never see them again
that's apostasy it's also pretense and the people who let it happen really are responsible before
God because confirmation was meant to be you are confirmed in the faith that's the reality of it
okay so louisa goes on my Jesus you say that you love me very much and then you permit this
tearing of my soul away from you how could your heart endure such a great pain if my and Jesus
said my daughter courage don't lose heart one who must rise above all now louisa has to rise
above all because she's the first having been born with original sin to rise to divine will
must descend to the lowest bottom now the descent into nothingness that's the lowest bottom
the descent into nothingness is safe is the safety net the problem about rising high
is that if you fall from a high mountain you're not going to survive if you fall from a little
stool in your kitchen you'll survive okay it's it's the height you've been to that that's the danger
and so in order to keep the saints safe the lord lets them go into a crisis in which they see
themselves as complete hypocrites you know and he brings them right down to reality that's a safety
net for them and if the lord does that then satan has nothing to attack okay so there's only safety
in humility or he brings us beyond humility into nothingness okay so this is the nothingness he
wants from us because you see if there's nothingness in us there's nothing for satan to attack but if
there's pride in us satan has a field day okay and it is said of my mother queen of all that she
was the humblest of all luke 148 and because she was to be the superior of all now i also want to
give you philippians chapter two verses six to ten that jesus was the greatest of all and he became
humbler than everybody else philippians two six to ten i also want to give you numbers twelve three
book of numbers twelve three because you see you see this in the old testament as well as the new
okay so it's said of my mother queen of all that she was the humblest of all because she was to
be superior to all but in order to be the humblest of all she had to descend to the lowest bottom
below everyone and and that's the frightful humiliation of standing at the foot of the cross
where her son is being killed as a criminal okay so it's public disgrace okay so my celestial mother
with the knowledge that she had of her god and creator of who she was a creature descended so
low that as she descended we would raise her up but so high that there was no one to equal her
now the gospel also says that i just don't have the reference right now he who humbles himself
will be exalted okay and he who exalts himself will be humbled okay so it's the same for you
in order to give the little daughter of my will primacy in my will good primacy means first place
okay having to raise her above all i make her descend to the lowest bottom below everyone
and the more she descends now once louise understands this she will let jesus plunge her into the abyss
peacefully it's just in the beginning when she doesn't know what he's about that she thinks she's done
something wrong and that's her upset but once she knows that he is taking her there to sort of
give her this this security in god then she's going to do it peacefully later on
so the more she descends the more i raise her and give her a place in the divine volition
oh how enraptured i am when i see one who is above all below everyone okay that's the image
of jesus on the cross so louise has to see herself as louise on the cross
now when we're struggling and we feel defeated or whatever else the problem is we don't think of
ourselves as frances on the cross we think of ourselves as frances failure or frances problem
do you know what i mean and the way you look at it can determine whether you come through quickly
or not whereas if you saw yourself as frances on the cross i'm going through this humiliation
whatever it is whether it's personal or family or anything else if you see it correctly through
his eyes it's an awful lot easier to deal with it and you see the people who stood at the foot of
the cross blessed mother her sister-in-law Mary of clopus john and mary of magdalene all could
sustain standing there because they could see where he was going with a joy that is set before him
he endures the cross despising the shame why because he told them three times before he died
that this was going to happen okay and so it's it's the way we see things that determines
what we can do with them okay we've another picture of course in john of jesus washing
the feet of his own disciples as an act of humility and we also have jesus saying to them
the son of man came not to serve but to be served and to give his life as a ransom for many
so the problem we have in the kingdom of god is that the king has his head lower than the rest of us
do you remember the the film the king and i or have your memory that long
the only scene that i remember in it is something that really spoke to me and still speaks to me
and that is the this dignified prideful english lady the king was trying to get her to sort of
lower her head a little bit so he nailed down but she wouldn't kneel she stood and then everybody
in the kingdom knelt because he knelt because he's the king but she wouldn't do and then eventually
somebody whispered to her that the correct protocol is for you to kneel if the king kneels so she
eventually kneels and then you see the grin on his face he got her to kneel and that's all he's
out he's not the rest of the kingdom is after it's this one and then he decides he's going lower and
he bends lower and he looks to see if she's bending and she gets a kick from behind you do what the
king does and finally he puts his head on the floor and laughs that's the only bit of the film i
remember you probably never struck with you but i saw it from the scriptural point of view
that the the king lowered himself lowered and anybody else and so the pride of this creature
had to come low and that's all he was trying to do is get her to lower her pride a little bit
so you can see you can learn a big lesson even from a film that's useless
so he says oh how unwraptured i am when i see one who is above all below everyone in other
words that you have the safety net of the nothingness okay so i don't know about you but what i do is i
put um things at the top of the page so that i'll see it the next time the safety net of nothingness
put at the top of the page so when i come to this the next time i'm looking for this the safety net
so jesus said i run and i fly to take your soul in my arms and i expand your boundaries within
my will you see the fact that she's she's gone back into our nothingness gives him the space
to be able to do more okay so therefore i allow everything for your good would you ever write that
down on a piece of paper and take it off the book and put it somewhere near where you sleep or
your fridge or something that the lord allows all kinds of things for your good
he allows people to oppose you and he allows all kinds of stuff okay and it's all for your good
the whole outfit and also uh to accomplish my highest designs upon you and of course we want
everything to be sort of comfortable and uh it's it can't be too comfortable if you're to grow
however i do not want you to waste time thinking over it it's mulling over and rationalizing it
however yeah i don't want that uh when i take you in my arms immediately put everything aside and
follow my will it's wonderful stuff isn't it okay so march the 12th 1923 we're talking about the
privation of jesus louisa said i felt i was dying of pain because of the privation of my sweet
jesus if he comes at all it's like a flash that escapes then as i couldn't take any more of having
compassion on me he came out from within my interior now he's there all the time you see
and as soon as i saw him i said to him my love what pain i feel i'm dying without you but dying
without dying which is the hardest of deaths i don't know how the goodness of your heart can
bear seeing me in this state of death it's only because of you like if it was some other reason
it's really different she can't just say to him it's your fault you know and jesus said my daughter
courage don't lose heart too much you are not alone in suffering this pain i too suffered it as
well as my dear mother now notice the triple jesus mary louisa all the time okay so make sure you
put the triple at the side and he said our privations were much harder than yours
how many times in my moaning humanity although it was inseparable from my
divinity in order to give place to expiation and pains since these were incapable of touching
the divinity the humanity had to remain alone and the divinity as though apart from the so how i
how much i felt this privation but it was necessary there you have an explanation that nobody else
but himself could give you in order for him to actually experience the pains the divinity had
to recede because if the divinity was there he'd have perfect happiness uh so the divinity in him
had to recede let the humanity come forward uh so that he could suffer this want to give you Colossians
1 verses 15 to 19 Colossians 1 verses 15 to 19 and Sam 22 verse 1 my god why have you forsaken me
because that's really what louisa is saying all the time okay so the heading i have for the next
paragraph is expiating for lost souls so expiating for lost souls is the heading uh you must know
that when the divinity issued the work of creation it also issued look at this all the glory all the
goods and the happiness that each soul was to receive not only in this life but also in heaven
in the celestial fatherland and we're told elsewhere that he has also issued the number of acts we're
going to do as well so that's Ephesians 1 1 to 14 Ephesians 1 1 to 14 now the whole part which
was destined for souls who are lost and you need to add by their own choice it's not his choice
who are lost by their own choice this part remained suspended having no one to whom to give itself
therefore having to complete everything and absorb everything inside of myself i offered myself
to suffer the privation which the very damned suffer in hell now in plain english jesus said
i will suffer their hell for them therefore on the day of general judgment not one soul in hell
will have one squeak against god because jesus will have suffered their hell for them
and for all who will be saved and i presume that's you and me he'll have suffered our
purgatory for us as well he will have suffered everything i talk about love this is incredible
isn't it um so oh how much this pain cost me it cost me the pains of hell you need to correct that
the pains of hell and ruthless debt but it was necessary having to absorb everything inside of
myself everything that came out of us in creation all the glory all the goods and the happiness
so as to let them come out of me and enter the field again for all those who wanted to enjoy them
so jesus is the source of life uh you get that all over the new testament is john one one two five
okay john one uh one two five collations two nine
john 14 six have you got them john one one two five collations two nine and john 14 six
so he said what i wanted was uh that i wanted let them come out of me and enter the field again
for all those who wanted to enjoy them so what the souls in hell lost jesus made available for
anybody who wants it that's like saying somebody has died and everything they possessed is now
left for the people left behind that makes sense doesn't it um i had to absorb all pains and the
very privation of my own divinity and you need to add louisa must follow suit because that's the
meaning of her privations as well so in the next part long paragraph he's telling us that the
experience of the absence of the lord is actually necessary for the salvation of souls the experience
of the absence of the lord i want to change the word privation is that okay the experience of the
absence of the lord is actually necessary for the salvation of souls now says john of the cross is
very strong on that that we all have to go through uh this sense of the absence of god now john of the
cross will simply use different words to louisa he will talk about eridity that that prayer becomes
impossible for you uh that you just can't think and you can't you can't produce a feeling or a
thought ranging as everything inside of you seems to dry up it's it's the privation uh what it's
it's just different words john of the cross is actually quite good on that and he tells you that
if you don't pray the same way with eridity as you did in fervor then you don't love god
in other words if you need the feelings of fervor to make you pray then you don't love god you love
the feelings of fervor does that make sense because over the years now i've i've done a lot
of spiritual direction and i remember a number of times people came to me and said at all over it
was only a bubble and very often these were people who had charismatic experiences and quite
quite strong charismatic experiences and you know they would have prayed for hours and hours they
did it and all night vigils and all kinds of stuff when they were in the fervor but they didn't
realize they were in the fervor and now they had gone into eridity and the thought was all over
i said no no no the honeymoon is over now you have your first monday morning back to work
roll up your sleeves this is where the spiritual life actually starts
not in the fervor because i said you loved the fervor and you didn't know it
and you see that the dawning in their eyes yeah i said the lord has done that to woo you
and to get you into commitment to him now you have to have the life together
and so you have to have everything that goes with life including the passion and death and
resurrection and the lot and when you put it into the context like that they were able to see it
you know and but i used to enjoy telling them that the honeymoon was over
i remember one person said to me your rudder i said i said i didn't do it here
i didn't give you the fervor and i didn't take it away so don't call me your rudder try somebody
else uh so let's come to this now having absorbed into myself jesus said all these goods of the whole
work of creation that's Colossians 118 being the head from which every good descent head means
source the head yeah the source from which every good descent from all generation Colossians and
Ephesians chapter one in both cases are great for this um i keep searching for souls who are like
me that's victim souls like me in pains and in works so as to let them partake in so much glory
and happiness which my humanity contains and now so much glory is not actually a good english
expression we would say as much glory as they can as their humanity allows and since not all souls
want to enjoy them in other words they don't want to pay the price of the cross
Nora are all of them empty of themselves now volumes one to four put it beside in your
thing volumes one to four we were told to empty ourselves of our ego remember and you're going
nowhere unless the ego has been dealt with and he says that if you're going on and there's still
some ego there then that becomes a block uh nor are all of them empty of themselves and of the
things up down here that's the world the flesh and the devil is the stuff you have down here
they're the things of the earth so in other words these people some people don't haven't completed
their detachment from the world and their detachment from themselves and if that detachment is not
complete that's volumes one to four if that detachment isn't complete then we can't take the wings
the weight is too heavy you know that when you're going on the air they insist on a certain weight
and when the birds are taking off on their flights they have to carry as little weight as possible
and some of them when they arrive after their long flight are announced weight
the birds and when we get to heaven the only weight we will have is love nothing else nothing else
going to get in there um so i i keep searching for souls the lord says to whom i may make known
and then withdraw you see you see the process i make known and then i withdraw that's the fervor
and the the privation now mother trees of calcutta is famous for this isn't she
she had wonderful experiences of god and then the lord told her to set up this new community
and as soon as she set it up and she had it on its feet not another screed that she got
she was in total darkness until death and she had privation for the rest of her days
but that's actually when she flourished because the joss man shall live by faith not by visions
okay um so i i make myself known and then i withdraw
so this forms the pain of my privation in these voids of themselves and of their acquired
knowledge of me in the privation that the soul suffers uh she comes to absorb into herself this
glory of my humanity which others reject so it's in the privation it's in the aridity it's in the
difficult times that you absorb this not in the happy times and yeah because what do you do in
happy times is sit back and you enjoy it you don't realize you're sitting back and enjoying but that's
what we do um had i not been almost always with you that's definitely volumes one to four
remember when when she started suffering the crucifixion and he wouldn't leave her he'd come
back many times the same day and then when she gets into particularly volume six onwards
she says larger it's not the same as it used to be a i don't have the same suffering and b
you're not coming the way you used to be and she she doesn't realize there's the turnover into the
new vocation uh so he said had i not been almost always with you you would have not known me
understood to the extent that you do uh nor would you have loved me to the extent that you do
because it's it's her personal experience of Jesus that has put her into this relationship
and you would not feel the pain of my privation now this is terribly important there are many people
trying to live a life of prayer and they don't notice the aridity because prayer is always
difficult for them prayers always a struggle so the privation is not a problem there are other
people whose faith is weak and therefore the privation of the Lord doesn't touch them at all it doesn't
matter there are people who go to mass on Sundays and they don't even know whether the Lord is present
or not so they don't even they don't ever have a sense of presence so a sense of absence doesn't
even work so privation the pain of privation depends on how deeply we know and love the Lord
okay um so he said if you didn't have these experiences you wouldn't feel the pain of privation nor
could it form in you the seed and the nourishment of this pain because the the nourishment of this
pain would be missing in you how many souls are without me and maybe they're even dead they grieve
if they're deprived of some little pleasure of whatever trifle but they have no pain and not even
a thought if they are deprived of me there you have it so this pain should console you because it
brings you the sure sign that I have come to you that you have known me and that your Jesus wants
to place in you the glory the goods and the happiness which others reject okay so I want to
give you john 1014 the other sheep that he has that he would like to bring to the fold as well if
only they would come and I want to give you Matthew 25 29 to those who have more more will be given
and to those who have nothing even that will be taken from them and it's their fault because they
don't they don't even want it you know so there are people like louisa who can't tolerate the
privation and there are others and they wouldn't know what you were talking about so march the 18th
1923 we have Jesus talking about the divine will again I was abandoning all of myself in the most
holy will of my sweet Jesus even though I felt I was without him and as though pierced in my heart
I thought to myself why did he speak to me so much about his eternal will if now he has left me
but I heard this is a contradiction rather his very words are piercings from my heart
which tear it to shreds and even though I'm resigned and I kiss those very piercings that
lacerate me and the hand that pierces me oh that's 10 out of 10 kiss the hand that causes the pain
okay so she's much further on than simply resignation resignation is not kissing the hand that actually
causes you the pain so she gets 10 out of 10 for this now so she's responding correctly to the
privation still I feel vividly that everything is over for me so if she's not in communication with
Jesus she feels life is finished for her but while I was thinking of this my sweet Jesus moved in
my interior and throwing his arms around my neck he told me my daughter my daughter do not fear
nothing is over between you and me your Jesus is always your Jesus for you there's another one to
take out of the book and put it somewhere where you can see it all the time your Jesus is always
your Jesus and for you the strongest thing that binds the soul is to dissolve her will in mine
how can I leave you and besides if I have spoken to you so much about my will it's as many bonds
of indissolable union now this is VIP PP okay but a VIP on this one he says for every contact you
make with the divine will it's an indissolable bond of union between you and him and just think
of it now at this stage you've probably done thousands and thousands of acts okay they are
thousands of threads making up a garment that's binding you completely to him it's not fantastic
and he says they're indissolable because a divine will act will never die never die
so he said these are as many bonds of indissolable union that I have between you and me and speaking
to you my eternal volition of bound your little will with the bonds of my eternal will watch this
for each word that I have spoken to you and that's each word that we're reading and trying to absorb
moreover you must know that in creating man our first supreme will was that he should live in our
volition and having to live in it he was to take what is ours so as to live at our expense
repaying our will with as many divine acts for as many human acts that he was doing our divine
will all he had to do in response to everything he was given was do his acts in the divine will
nothing else and how easy it is to do it this in order to enrich him with all the goods which
our will contains but man wanted to live of his own will you have to put the little old wn in
for english man wanted to live of his own will at his own expense and therefore he exiled himself
now notice this is the work of man it's not the work of god he exiled himself from his father
land and lost all these goods so my goods remained without heirs they were immense and nobody possessed
them therefore my humanity that should be a capital am according to this book my humanity came to
take possession of all these goods by living every instant in the divine will and that's what he's
asking us to try and reach a point that every instant we're living in the divine will it wanted
to live always at the expense of the divine will being born growing suffering working and dying
in the eternal kiss of the supreme volition and as i kept living in it i was given the possession
of the many unemployed goods which ungrateful man has put into oblivion and in this apostasy
that we're living in i called jesus the unemployed savior he's not called on
so in the last paragraph here it's how to take possession of the goods of the divine will
how to take possession of the goods of the divine will i give you these headings to make it
easier for you the next time you come back to the text how to take possession of the goods of the
divine will so jesus said now my daughter if my infinite wisdom has spoken to you so much about
my will it was not just to give you simple knowledge my book says news that's knowledge no but to make
known to you the living in my will and the goods that it contains and as you walk your way in it
you see the lord intends that we're reading this we're absorbing it and we're trying to live it
as you walk in it you take possession of it that's with every single act and every single desire
you're taking more and more possession and my humanity did everything it took possession
of everything not for myself alone but to open the doors to my other brothers that's john 10 16
john 10 16 i have waited for so many centuries and many generations have gone by and i will still
wait but man must return to me on the wings of my will i think that's brilliant isn't it
eagle wings Ephesians one seven to ten
man must return to me on the wings of my will from which he came therefore you are to be the first
to be welcomed and let my words be a spur for you to take possession of the divine will as well as
chains which bind you so tightly as to never let you go out of my will so louise is to be the first
will we go out to follow her okay so march the 23rd 1923 the sorrows of blessed mother
i was thinking of the sorrows of my celestial mother and my beloved jesus moving in my interior
told me my daughter i was the first king of sorrows and being man and god i had to centralize
everything within me in order to have primacy over everything even over sorrow now the one thing
that earth gave jesus that heaven couldn't give him was sorrow sorrow and grief and again that's
Colossians 118 those of my mother were nothing other than the reverberations of mine which being
reflected in her made her share all my sorrows which piercing her filled her with such bitterness
and pain that she felt herself dying at each reverberation of my sorrows you know the name
medium which was her name means it has two meanings it means exalted one and it also means bitterness
so in the Hebrew ma or e with a little stroke over it mad a means bitterness
it's very interesting when you go to the book of Ruth because Naomi said to her
daughter-in-law don't call me Naomi call me mare call me bitterness
so at the side i want to give you Ephesians chapter one verse four and verse seven
but love sustained her and gave her life again now the centrality of love in these writings is
something we're going to have to really look at therefore not only for honor but also for the
rights of justice she was the first queen of the immense sea of her sorrows now it's immense
because she lived in the divine will all the time okay while she was saying this while he was saying
this louisa said i seem to see my mother in front of jesus and everything that jesus contained the
sorrows and the piercings of that most holy heart were reflected in the heart of the sorrowful queen
and those reflections many swords look to 35 the sword will pierce your heart remember
look to 35 many swords formed the heart of the pierced mother and these swords were marked by
a fiat of light that's the divine will she said fiat everything in which she was circumfused
and in the midst of so many fiats of most rafolgent light which gave her much glory
that there are no words generated okay so in the next paragraph we have mary's sword of sorrow
and i want to give you luke 138 luke 138 then jesus continued saying it was not the sorrows
that constituted my mother as queen and made her shine with so much glory but it was my omnipotent
fiat it's the divine will that made her who she was it's the divine will that will make us who we are
or who are meant to be it was my omnipotent fiat which was braided to her every act and sorrow
and constituted itself the life of each one of her sorrows so in other words she did everything
on the divine level hence its immense so my fiat was the first act that formed the sword giving her
the intensity of pain that the divine will wanted my fiat could place all the sorrows
it wanted in that pierced heart adding piercing upon piercings pains upon pains without a shadow
of the slightest resistance because she surrendered completely now notice the description of interior
pain there is the same as you get in the hours of the passion for the passion of love that jesus
said he had a passion of love and the passion of sins and then the passion of the jews do you
remember so the passion of love is what gave him all these interior sins so if you if you write
at the side the passion of love no for miry the passion of love passion of love for jesus it was
the the passion of love the passion of sins and the passion of the jews you get that in the hours
of the passion you get it i think in the agony and on the contrary she felt honored that my fiat
would constitute itself the life of even a heartbeat of hers and my fiat gave her complete glory and
constituted her the true and legitimate queen okay so the last paragraph here is the fiat as life
and when we begin we have the fiat as individual acts and every time we remember okay the fiat as
life is a different matter altogether that your whole being is flowing in surrender to the divine
will and so this turns the human into the into the divine and that's roman's age 18
so the fiat as life turning the human into the divine and it's roman's 8 18 now
who will be the souls jesus says in whom i can reflect the reverberations of my sorrows
and my very life it will be those who have my fiat as life now that means that you're at the stage
where the divine will is running your life and that your will has surrendered lots of people are not
at that point this fiat will make them absorb my reflections and i will be generous and sharing
with them that which my will operates in me so if you want to know if you're there
he's going to be very generous in sharing his sorrows
just as he was very generous in sharing his sorrows with his blessed mother and with louisa
because that's what we're talking about isn't it okay so we're not talking about people at
the level of doing isolated acts were much much further around than that therefore in my will
i await souls to give them the true dominion and the complete glory of each act and pain
that they may suffer okay the operating and suffering outside of my will i don't recognize
i could say i've nothing to give you what's the will that animates you and doing this suffering
get your reward from that one is that interesting many times doing good and suffering if my will
is not present in them it can be miserable slavery that degenerate into passions while it is my will
alone that gives true dominion true virtues true glory such as to transform the human into
the divine going to be a whole lot of scriptures is that okay Matthew six one
if your prayers are only to get other people's attention then you have your reward
so matthew six one and also verse six verse eighteen and verse twenty one
so jesus gives the example of prayer fasting and ambs giving just to get attention from other
people and he said won't you get the attention that's it gods off the hook you didn't do it for him
completely useless thing okay matthew seven twenty one to twenty three some people will say to him
lord lord you walked in our streets you you we worked mighty miracles for you and he said i
won't i don't know you and he said i don't know you if you did that in your own will
and you didn't do it in his will so it's going to be people in hell who have worked miracles
to can you name one Judas here and i want to give you at the end of this when jesus says that
my will alone gives true dominion true virtues true glory such as to transform the human into
the divine i want to give you Romans eight twenty eight to thirty
i think we'll stop there because the next one is too long and it will take you quite a bit